playstation is gearing up to buy some
more studios and halo infinite is
getting some special content
sony interactive entertainment president
jim ryan has promised that the company
will continue to acquire more studios in
the future following a big buying spree
in 2021 sony acquired 5 studios in 2021
and in 2022 so far it announced deals to
buy destiny 2 developer bungie and jade
raymond's haven studios in an appearance
on the latest playstation podcast ryan
said one of the ways playstation is
growing its business is through buyouts
and fans can expect this to continue
ryan made the announcement during a
wider comment regarding why sony's new
version of playstation plus will not add
day one releases like xbox game pass
does like he said earlier this week ryan
explained that sony won't put new
releases on a subscription service on
day 1 because investing in games and
studios leads to a virtuous cycle where
success begets success sony wants to
make games that are bigger and have
better narratives and ryan said sticking
with the traditional paid model is a way
to keep this cycle intact going forward
and even though sony's new playstation
plus program won't have new releases on
day one its higher tiers give members
access to a catalog of ps4 and ps5 games
as well as a library of classic titles
to be announced later switching gears to
some xbox news now april is here and
that means that there are new free games
with gold available now for xbox live
gold and game pass ultimate subscribers
right now subscribers can claim another
site and outpost colloquiax you can also
still claim street power soccer until
april 15th set in a steampunk version of
london at the turn of the 20th century
another site stars a girl and her cat
after kid loses her eyesight she has to
rely on hodge the cat to help her
explore the underground world another
site is free all throughout april
outpost colloquix is a city building
management sim set on a space station
that was an xbox live arcade launch
title on the 360 back in 2005. it's up
for grabs in the first half of the month
and in the back half of the month
subscribers can grab the off-road racing
game mx vs atv alive in other xbox news
343 industries community director brian
jarrod confirmed halo infinite will one
day feature content inspired by the
paramount plus tv show he did not
provide any hints at when the content
might arrive though he did tease however
that 343 will be looking to determine
what threads and nods from the tv series
can be added to infinite through its
live service model technically speaking
halo infinite and the tv series take
place in different timelines with the
show embracing the silver timeline that
said jared said fans can expect nods
back and forth between the two also in
the interview jared said that the halo
tv show is aiming to be an onboarding
experience for those who haven't
necessarily played the games jared said
he hopes there is more cross-pollination
between fans of the show and fans of the
game and if you didn't know the full
first episode of the halo tv show is on
paramount plus's youtube channel for
free so
i think it's i think it's about time i
go watch it
if you've watched it let me know what
you think in the comments below and i'll
see you next week